the FAA is under increasing pressure to
ground Boeing's top-selling passenger
plane after the deadly crash in Ethiopia
more than a hundred 737 max series
planes are still flying in North America
the US and Canada are the only two major
countries allowing the planes to
continue operating the only two major
countries at least 39 nations including
European Union countries grounded max
planes Airlines in at least six other
countries and territories have also done
so investigators are still trying to
determine the cause of Sunday's crash
that killed 157 people including eight
Americans it was the second deadly
accident involving a 737 max in five
months Kris Van Cleave is at
Washington's Reagan National Airport
with the safety debate Chris good
morning good morning the FAA says it has
no basis to justify grounding the 737
max at this point but it's important to
note the agency has no information from
flight 302s black boxes to senior Trump
administration officials tell CBS News
the White House sees no benefit to
interfering or second-guessing the FAA
fearing a rush to judgment could do more
harm than good I'm advising members of
my own family and friends change planes
on Capitol Hill Tuesday the list of
lawmakers on both sides calling for the
FAA to ground the Boeing 737 max grew to
more than 10 mm senator Mitt Romney it
makes sense to ground aircraft has been
involved in two very tragic accidents in
only six months Transportation Secretary
Elaine Chao says her department which
oversees the FAA is working closely with
the National Transportation Safety Board
and Ethiopian investigators to determine
the cause of Sunday's crash of Ethiopian
Airlines flight 302 the 737 max would be
the fourth plane in US history to be
grounded by federal regulators in 2013
the FAA ordered Airlines to temporarily
stop flying the Boeing 787 due to fire
concerns with the planes batteries FAA
has probably the most rigorous
certification process of any agency
former FAA assistant administrator Scott
Brenner says grounding planes without
substantive reason sets a dangerous
precedent
the FAA is saying we have a system in
place so let's not start changing it
just because we have some public
pressure going against us
CBS News travel editor Peter Greenberg
says it's a difficult balance for the
FAA the FAA has always had a conflict
when they were established by an act of
Congress they were supposed to make an
enforced safety policy and then promote
the business of aviation they can't do
both
now Boeing CEO had a call with President
Trump yesterday where he says he remains
confident in the safety of the 737 max
airplanes we are aware of at least five
anonymous complaints from pilots through
a NASA database set up for pilots to
report issues where at least two cases
where you had pilots talk about the auto
pilot pushing the nose of the max down
after takeoff the autopilot is a
different system than the one that's
being looked at in the lion air crash
from October it's also not clear if what
happened there were pilot errors lack of
familiarity with a brand-new airplane or
something larger at this point we do
know that the three pilots unions out of
United American and Southwest are
standing behind the aircraft so are the
airlines who say they have seen no
systemic no it doe data whatsoever
anything systemic wrong with the
airplane in more than a hundred thousand
hours of flight time beyond all right
Chris and just this morning view the
Ethiopian Airlines CEO said that the
pilot did receive training for the max
eight plane so this story will continue
for sure